that's why I came here now I do
freestyle rap that's wrap that you make
up it's improvised it's not written or
prepared we'll get five random topics
then we'll drop a beat to a freestyle
rap and we'll start over here let's get
a suggestion from this corner what would
you like a rap about president tripping
the president tripping oh like yesterday
he was giving like a commencement thing
and he kind of it because it was
wonderful wasn't it because it was he
didn't even move he just turned and
collapsed which was
it was wonderful really usually you have
to take a step to trip he
imploded in a way
um cool uh lovely stuff the president
tripping uh middle middle of the room
what would you like a rap about
pardon
Jenna it's it's a name
should I know is it is it a you know is
it like Madonna is it like a famous
one-person name who's Jenna
who
hot girl Jenna
are you perhaps called Jenna my friend
I do my own PR I'm Jenna okay
Jenna Jenna the hot girl um great
middle front of the room uh don't just
shout out a Christian name what would
you like a rap about
liquid nitrogen oh very good have you
have you had any warts or verrucas
removed recently
liquid nitrogen Jenna the president
tripping this this side of the middle
and then we'll come to you for the last
what you guys want to rap about
traveling with your mom uh is your
mother here yes
but via what means have you traveled
recently
you're from Canada oh my gosh
they're just jealous of your health care
that's all that is
traveling with your Canadian mother and
then this segment the final suggestion
make it the best
there were two I heard marriage bellowed
out by a man so what good on you and
then someone else said
shrooms was that did you say shrooms
I think you I'm a gynecologist on
shrooms okay yes
why not
traveling with your Canadian mother a
gynecologist on shrooms Jenna the
president tripping liquid nitrogen maybe
marriage it was probably slightly bested
by gynecologist on shrooms I do
apologize for that
and all my band here they're going to
drop a delicious delightful beat
why are you laughing were you like oh
this can't actually be real it's not
really gonna happen but they've got
they've got to they've got it music well
uh Jeremy and red are gonna play the
music I'm gonna make up the beats the
rap be as good as your suggestions so uh
let's go for it
I hope the rap's fun 10 out of 10 there
one girl at the back shouting out Jenna
that's my name I imagine how you look
probably the long blonde hair looking
pretty cooking like a dime walking down
the street all the guys slobber when
they walk past they say I wanna meet
this lady what a surname we don't know
it's a mystery maybe put that old shape
ring on the finger you could be wedding
then before you go to bed you should be
heading to the gynecologist check please
you gotta make sure there's no STDs or
STIs Inside Man does two and then maybe
marriage is coming to you but wait step
back rewind there to the room the OBGYN
is consuming the shrooms four hours ago
yes I could see she was brewing up the
mushrooms in the pot of the tea still of
cybin sliding in the cup she starts
coming up and she's like what the [__]
this is insane the lady's there I feel
like I could climb inside her labia it's
like a big wet cave the Wall's all pink
this is what a shroom me gynecologists
thinks I know this is slightly forward
if you're with your mum and you're
bringing her for sure you've got to be
careful should a warned there's a white
guy rapping maybe Mom you could spend
this time napping dreaming about things
that you like more maple syrup that's
what you guys adore and truck protests
oh yes bro and people going isn't he
dish he Trudeau the man when you travel
with your mum I should ask do you give
her the upgrade and go first class
you've got to Splash the cash she pushed
you out from inside but her doctor
didn't imbibe all the shrooms because in
Canada they're more regulated if you've
got a wart then you should be persuaded
to get it minus 40 and 50 burn it off
quickly kind of liquidy nitrogen that's
different you might guess it's not like
Fast and the Furious with the liquid
nitrous it's the liquid nitrogen it
looks like dry ice a chemist over there
is like my eyes are bulging in the back
of my head last one yeah Biden he's
almost dead he's like in his 80s can
[__] old he needs to have a handrail
which he could hold but he didn't he
stood there on stage why are you
groaning at me and getting in raised
he's like there's two years of my tenure
then four more and then he collapsed
[__] down onto the floor
foreign
[Music]
you guys are lovely my name is Chris
Turner thank you very much good night
goodbye
ah what did I say what did I say